in the last video we talked about
pensions and how they're defined benefit
plans and how they could get underfunded
or how there could be temptation for
people to under fund them in this video
I want to make things a little bit more
concrete by looking at actual numbers
especially at the state level so right
over here it's a map of obviously the
United States and what it shows is is
how funded the pension liabilities are
in the different states so for example
actually you know Texas for example 83%
of their pension liabilities are funded
they've set aside eighty-three percent
of the right amount of money to fund
their pension obligations not a hundred
percent it is underfunded but it's not
crazy California pretty high seventy
eight percent but one of these states is
probably jumping out at you probably
because it has been shaded in red and
that is the state of Illinois and
Illinois is in trouble because it's only
funded 45% of its pension obligations
and then Illinois really jumps out
because it's it's it's in red but
there's a lot of states that are pretty
close to Illinois Louisiana 56% Oklahoma
56% Kentucky 54% West Virginia 58% and
this is an issue because they've set
aside in the past very little money for
the pension obligations that are
starting to hit now especially that you
have a retiring baby boomer population
and in order to meet those obligations
those promised obligations they're going
to have to dig into money that was being
spent other places that going in the
past when they were under funding the
pension they were able to fund other
things nicely it but not fund the
pension and kind of kick the can down
the road but now that they're there can
can't be kicked any further it's going
to have to go the other way around
you're gonna have to take money from
other things to fund your pensions and
to make it clear let's focus on the
state of Illinois so this right over
here there's a couple of things going on
in this kind of yellow ochre color and
I'll circle it in yellow ocher they were
talking about the total liabilities and
just to make this graph clear it's not
just the yellow core part this total
liabilities the entire height of each of
these bars is the total is
the total liabilities and you see how it
has just completely it's completely
blossomed here and there's a lot of
things that go into the total
liabilities the same things that we
talked about in the last video there are
things like return on investment return
on investment if you're in a low
interest rate environment like we are
now for example my money in my savings
account I think is getting like 0.4%
interest it's getting pretty much no
interest if you're in a low interest
rate environment if you're not getting
good returns and a lot of pensions tend
to go into very safe assets but those
are getting very low returns you're
going to have to set aside more money
and so you see these of these
obligations essentially just just
growing dramatically on top of that you
have things like cost-of-living
adjustments cost-of-living adjustments
these are attempts at at kind of
factoring and inflation how much things
are costing in that region but there are
also sometimes negotiated and sometimes
and especially in the case of illinois'
they've grown faster than the rate of
inflation and so you have these
liabilities and you see that they're
getting less and less well funded so if
we go right over here and this is what
this Green Line is the funding ratio so
how well funded are these liabilities
read say the red part of the bar is a
part that is not paid for and the Green
is the ratio of the red is the ratio of
or is the ratio of what is funded
essentially this higher part it's the
ratio of this this this part right over
here to the entire bar so it's the ratio
of this to the entire bar and you see
right over here Illinois's is in a boy
is in a bad situation they're total
liabilities are 138 billion this is in
million so it's 138 thousand million so
it's 138 billion this is for one state
and 85 or 86 billion of that is unfunded
that they have to figure out somewhere
to get the money because of the bright
amount of money was not being set aside
and to do that they're going to have to
dig in into other things so this right
over here this is the pension
contribution so let me circle this so in
this yellow color once again is the
pension contribution
and now the state they're going to have
to in order to in order to get to a
funded position they're going to have to
make up for all of the underfunding of
the past and also the the other factors
that are making this obligation even
larger they're going to have to dig into
other things and so you see right over
here in yellow these are the pension
these are the contributions that they're
going to have to make for the pension
and you see that growing it's going
growing to in excess by 2018 of 6
billion a year but what's really
fascinating about this graph is it's
passing up total education funding in
the state so the cost of funding
retirements so the cost of funding
retirements for people who have already
done service for the state but aren't in
service to the state right now is going
to pass up is going to pass up and this
is happening very soon is going to pass
up actual spending on a statewide basis
on education and at the state level
education is a major major major
expenditure so it's going to be passing
up a major expenditure or very important
educate expenditure for the future of
the state based on past obligations and
to understand where this is going and
just to understand Illinois situation
there's 750,000 illinois easy item
notices Illinoisans illinoisians who are
member of the state's 5 pension system
so this is the Teachers Retirement
System this is the state universities
Retirement System this is the state
employees retired system this is the
judges Retirement System you see there's
a lot fewer judges in that there's many
more teachers who have been retired many
who have been in the state universities
and this right over here is the General
Assembly very few people who are in the
Illinois State Assembly and you can see
kind of comparable salaries this is the
retirement benefit not just the salaries
this is how much on average these folks
are getting once they retire on an
annual basis so you see that they're
pretty reasonable especially for the
judges especially for the judges
although that they are they are a small
fraction but in all fairness this was
promised to these people they planned
they probably took lower compensation
while they were working with the
expectation that they would be able to
get these benefits once they retired
they also probably stayed in the jobs
longer this is a way of retaining in
because they knew that they were going
to get this benefit so you might say oh
these are really really great benefits
but at the same time these people
probably sacrificed other things in
order to get these benefits now but it's
a very hard question when you look at
this you like okay you say well these
people they've done service they put
these expectations but the same time
you're like well you know this is really
cutting in and this is just one thing
that I'm showing it's really cutting
into very important areas of investment
for the entire state so the whole reason
of really just surfacing this this whole
pension issue is just to put this in and
hopefully people understand what the
issues are because that's the only way
that that fairly hard decisions are
going to have to be made decisions on
cutting necessary investment or
restructuring or who knows what it might
be I don't I don't envy the people who
have to make these decisions